si tiene un problema grave con la
válvula aórtica del corazón su médico
puede recomendarle un implante
transcatéter de la válvula aórtica o t a
b I también se lo conoce como reemplazo
de la válvula aórtica por catéter o t a
br
la válvula aórtica es una de las cuatro
válvulas en el corazón se encuentra
entre el ventrículo izquierdo o cámara
inferior izquierda y el gran vaso
sanguíneo que suministra sangre
oxigenada al cuerpo llamado aorta
cuando el ventrículo izquierdo se
contrae Durante cada latido empuja la
sangre a través de tres barbas flexibles
en forma de copa que constituyen la
válvula aórtica
cuando el ventrículo izquierdo Se relaja
la válvula aórtica se cierra para evitar
que la sangre vuelva al ventrículo
izquierdo
a medida que envejece la válvula aórtica
puede desarrollar depósitos de calcio
que hacen que las balvas se vuelvan más
gruesas y menos flexibles en este caso
es posible que las válvulas no se abran
completamente
esta afección denominada estenosis
valvular aórtica calcificada Crea una
abertura estrecha que reduce la cantidad
de sangre que fluye hacia la aorta y
sale al cuerpo
así la pared del ventrículo izquierdo Se
engrosa porque tiene que trabajar más
para bombear la sangre por la abertura
estrecha de la válvula
al comienzo de la intervención el médico
realiza una pequeña incisión en la ingle
tras crear una abertura en un vaso
sanguíneo llamado arteria femoral el
médico le inserta un tubo flexible
denominado vaina introductora
a través de la vaina el médico introduce
un alambre guía flexible en la arteria
femoral
este alambre guía se pasa a través de su
arteria femoral
hasta llegar a la aorta
a continuación se introduce el alambre
guía a través de la abertura de la
válvula aórtica hasta el ventrículo
izquierdo el médico usa el alambre guía
para pasar un tubo flexible llamado
catéter a través de la válvula aórtica
se expande un balón en la punta del
catéter para ensanchar la abertura de la
válvula aórtica y empujar las valvas de
la válvula hacia los costados después de
desinflar el balón su médico le retira
el catéter
la válvula de reemplazo consiste en una
válvula de tejido rodeada por una malla
metálica llamada stent
la válvula de reemplazo se comprime y se
coloca en la punta de otro catéter
este catéter se inserta a través de la
válvula aórtica
cuando el catéter alcanza la abertura de
la válvula aórtica el médico expande el
balón situado debajo de la válvula de
reemplazo para expandirla junto con el
stent
tras la colocación de la nueva válvula
aórtica el médico desinfla el balón
el stent sostiene y mantiene la válvula
de reemplazo en su lugar
el catéter y el alambre guía son
retirados
al final de la intervención la vaina
introductora de la ingle es retirada se
cierra la incisión en la piel
hay otra incisión en el otro lado de la
ingle a través de la cual se insertan
instrumentos para monitorear su corazón
durante el procedimiento
esta incisión en la piel también se
cierra
Para obtener más información sobre el
implante transcatéter de la válvula
aórtica consulte a su médico